okay today I'm going to talk to you
about finding the relative formula mass
what the relative formula mass basically
means is we're trying to find the
relative mass of a particular molecule
so for example let's say I was trying to
find a mass of sodium carbonate na2co3
so the first thing I need to do is I
need to figure out which elements are in
this molecule so I've got sodium i've
got carbon and i've got oxygen so the
next step is to just say how many of
each of these atoms I have so for sodium
because there's this two here I know
there's two sodium atoms for carbon
because there's no number I know there's
just one of them and for oxygen because
there's that three there I know that
there are three of them okay so that was
my first step what I need to do now is I
need to find the atomic mass of each of
these atoms so to do that sometimes I
give it to you in the question if they
don't you just use your periodic table
remember this is always at the back of
your exam paper so first of all sodium
is just here so sodium my mass number
remember that's the bigger number I
always think of mass think of the word
massive it's the bigger number so for
sodium that is 23 so each atom has a
mass of 23 for carbon that is just here
each item has a mass of 12 a relative
mass of 12 and finally for oxygen each
atom has a mass of 16 so what I need to
do next is I just need to figure out the
the mass of each element within this
because there's two sodium atoms it's
two times 23 which is 46 a carbon
there's only one of them so each atoms a
mass of 12 so that's 12 and for the
first one because there's three oxygens
the answer here is 48 so the final thing
that I need to do right now is I just
need to add them together so 46 plus 12
plus 48 equals now always always usually
calculate or even if you think you could
do it in your head just to check your
answer the answer is 106 so that is how
to find the relative formula mass only
time when it gets a little trickier it's
when you have something in brackets so
let me show you right now so I've got
calcium hydroxide for example as you
could see this o H is in brackets so
we'll see how what that means in just a
second so first of all let's split it up
just like we did before
so figure out which atoms we actually
have it in here in the first place now
what we then do is you figure out how
many of them we have so for calcium
that's nice and easy it's not in the
brackets there's no number here so I
know there's just one of them now here
is the slightly trickier bit whenever we
have a brackets in chemistry it means
we've got to lots of everything in the
brackets so it means we've got to basic
saying we've got to lots of Oh H so
we've got two O's and we've got two H's
so here my oxygen I have two of them and
my hydrogen I also have two of them once
you've done that step the rest is the
same all that you need to do is use your
periodic table so calcium is right here
it's got a mass of 40 relative mass of
40 so one times 40 oxygen I found that
out before in my last question that was
16 and hydrogen that just has a mass of
1 so let's quickly have a look at this
so 1 times 40 is 40
2016 is 32 and 2 times 1 is 2 so just
like before my final step all I need to
do is add these numbers together so 40
plus 32 plus 2 again even if I think I
could do this on a calculator I'm gonna
double-check 74 so that is how you find
the relative formula mask step 1 figure
out which atoms you have step 2 find out
how many of each item you have step 3
figure out the mass number from the
periodic table step 4
calculate the relative mass of each item
step 5
add them all together thank you very
much